-I always like seeing you.
Thank you so much
for coming back
and coming to visit me.
You want to sit on the couch?
-I'll do anything you say.
-No, no, no, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
You keep looking at it.
But, yeah, you can lay down.
[ Laughter ]
Sure, of course, yeah.
Let's talk
about your life, yeah.
Let's talk about your career.
[ Laughter and applause ]
F. Murray Abraham,
you've had a fantastic career.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I have, I have.
It's been fanta--
Where is everybody?
-We're here.
We're at "The Tonight Show."
Okay, perfect.
I wanted to ask you a quick
question because I heard this
and tell me
if it's true or false.
Not about "White Lotus,"
about you.
Is that you got your start,
or one of your breaks,
being a Santa for Macy's.
-Yeah, I was, yeah.
I took it very seriously, too.
-Oh, yeah.
-No, no, I really did.
It was the one that was
in Queens at the time
and there were a lot of like
immigrants that were living
in Queens at the time.
Very diverse.
And I used to ask, quietly,
the parents of the kids
what language they spoke
and then I would write out
how to say Merry Christmas
in their language.
So, when the kid sat on my lap,
I'd say Merry Christmas
in that language
because it was --
and the kid would go --
[ Laughter ]
"It's Santa Claus!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, boy, that's a great story.
-Yeah, it's true.
That was really --
I was really serious
about it.
-That's a great -- I mean,
of all your acting roles,
that's one of --
that's probably one
of your best that you've got,
Santa Claus
in different languages.
You know, I want to say
congratulations.
You were nominated for an Emmy
for your voiceover work
[ Cheering and applause ]
in Marvel's --
in "Moon Knight,"
playing this character.
That is you.
[ Laughter ]
That is what -- Yeah.
You're the voice of
Khonshu.
-Khonshu.
[ Laughter ]
Is this a whole new fan base
for F. Murray Abraham?
-It's funny,
I get fan mail from China.
-Oh, is that right?
-For this voice. I really do.
I was going to have lunch
at a hangout of mine
in the Village and it was closed
because there was a film,
a student film was being made.
It's in the Village, near NYU.
And I'm looking like
in the window
and one of the kids,
young people
who's making the film, says,
"Are you in this movie?!"
And I looked at him
and someone else came over
and says,
"Do you know who this is?!
This is the voice of Khonshu!"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-I swear. That's the truth.
-Out of all your years
of acting...
-Yeah.
-...you've won an Academy Award.
-It's alright. I'll take it
where I can get it.
-Yeah, come on.
Can we talk about "White Lotus"?
-Oh, yeah.
-We have to. You're fantastic.
The finale aired
this past Sunday.
No spoilers. Got giant ratings.
Everyone's talking about it.
I don't want to give
too much away.
But what did you think
of the finale,
can you say that?
-Oh. Oh.
You got to -- You got to see it.
For those of you who haven't
seen it, you're in for a shock.
It was some surprise.
-Were you surprised, though?
-Yeah!
I decided not to see
anything until --
until the last segment
and I saw it this Sunday.
I was really blown away.
I'm not going to say anything
about it because
you'll be surprised.
But I got to tell you
this, man --
it was the best experience
of my life.
You got to go to Sicily.
I mean, you really do.
-I mean, it's beautiful.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-We're not giving away
any trips to Sicily.
[ Laughter ]
What more do you want?!
Gosh!
Give you cars, sweaters,
Janet Jackson tickets.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, come on.
But you go there and Mike White.
I know he's a genius,
but is he a genius?
-Absolutely, man.
-He is, right?
He's unbelievably genius.
-I mean, how many people
do you work for that you want
to work for again
and again and again?
-Yeah.
-Am I right? Am I right?
-And you'd do anything for.
-You're working for him, right?
-Why are you looking
at the band?
Everyone's very happy here,
yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But you get offered the role
and it's just because they go,
"Hey, we want Murray Abraham.
-Oh.
He's the best."
-You read the script
and you want to do this.
Are you kidding? I got lines
in there that are deathless.
I got lines that I said
in that thing
that people were saying to me
on the street.
-Yeah. What is your
favorite line?
-Oh, my favorite line was
we were talking about the --
the aesthetics of a penis.
[ Laughter ]
Like -- Yeah, it was like,
"Is it beautiful?
Is it --"
And I said, "Well, it's a penis.
It's not a sunset."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, that's a great line.
-That's a good line.
That's a good line.
"It's not a sunset."
-And people in New York, I mean,
I don't know what --
They'll say,
"Hey, penis! Hey!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I get the same thing.
I get the same exact thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's funny.
-How did they describe
the character to you when you --
-Oh, no, no.
You know,
you just give me the script
and you go,
"I got to do this, man."
-You just have to.
-No, no, you got to do this.
-Because he's
a little problematic,
but you make him funny
and charming.
-Yeah, well, they're like people
I grew up with.
-They are, yeah.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm first-generation American.
-Oh, wow.
-I mean, these people.
I'm half Italian, half Syrian,
[ Cheering and applause ]
and these people were like that,
you know?
-Yeah.
And you and Michael Imperioli
got together.
You felt like father
and son to me.
-Well, I got to tell him, man,
Michael and I became
very good friends.
-Yeah?
-Yeah. It's lucky
when that happens.
Doesn't happen too often,
you know?
He's a good guy.
-Yeah.
-You just got nominated
for a Golden Globe
for your performance...
-Oh.
-...so, congratulations on that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Awww!
Yeah. Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Are you --
Do you get excited about that?
You get a Golden Globe?
-Well, I already have one.
[ Laughter ]
-So you go -- Yeah.
-[ Snaps fingers ]
-Wow! Wow!
Put it next to your Oscar.
I'd like another Golden Globe.
-Ooh, yeah! Can we get him two?
Let's get him another
Golden Globe, come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's well-deserved.
-And I'd like another Oscar.
-Yeah, you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, while we're at it.
While we're at it, why not?
Everyone wins.
I want to show a clip.
Here's F. Murray Abraham
in "The White Lotus."
Take a look at this.
-They probably don't want
to be escorts.
They're just poor and victims
of a [bleep] system.
-Women aren't all saints, Albie.
They're just like us.
-Have a good lunch.
[ Scoffs ]
[ Chair scrapes floor ]
-Where are you going?
-Dad, what is the matter
with you?
I-I mean, you almost just --
-Just what?
-You know what.
I'm trying to smooth things over
with Albie and with everyone
and that would -- you know,
that would really not be good.
-I can't be responsible
for everything I say.
I'm concussed.
I just hit my head.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
"I can't be respons--
Hey, I'm concussed."
-Thank you, man.
F. Murray Abraham, everybody.
-Thank you very much.
-"The White Lotus" is available
now on HBO and HBO Max.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.
-Thank you.